let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast
real and raw political and social
commentary the freedom to oppress the
rights of other people is not liberty
you [ __ ] eating [ __ ] ah the smell of
freedom of speech this is the tony
michaels podcast and this is tony
michaels
hey tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
tuesday
[Music]
everyone thinks
freedom of speech is reborn
because elon musk now owns twitter he
doesn't own twitter yet you [ __ ]
boneheads
he doesn't own it yet and he didn't
march down to the twitter headquarters
with duffel bags full of 44 billion
dollars and they signed it over to him
that is not how it works
holy actual [ __ ] how and how in the hell
how in the hell is it that the right
wing is just [ __ ] stupid they they
think elon musk now owns twitter because
they accepted his bid yesterday that was
the news the news was that twitter
accepted
elon musk bid
for
twitter
in other words elon musk put a bid in on
twitter
they took it seriously because elon must
show how he would
pay the 44 billion they took that
seriously and they accepted the bid
elon musk does not own twitter today
frankly
i'm of the belief and you can prove me
wrong you can go back and roll the tape
and say oh you were [ __ ] wrong i
actually don't i i still
i still am very skeptical that elon musk
won't flake on this deal
you know how many deals elon musk flakes
on this guy
won't even [ __ ] sit for a full
haircut i'm gonna prove it
he flakes on his barber
for haircuts what makes you think he
might not flake on this deal and besides
they've just accepted his bid what if
there's another bid that comes in
really [ __ ] stupid that
self-proclaimed free market capitalists
in this country have no idea the
difference between a public a private
corporation they have no idea that elon
musk isn't going to just own twitter
he's going to own the corporation that
owns twitter
they have no [ __ ] clue that he is
actually
subject to federal state laws civil laws
criminal laws like this is so [ __ ]
stupid
it's really [ __ ] stupid did you know
did you know at one time in in our
nation's history that twitter the
company twitter was private
the company twitter was private until it
released its ipo its initial public
offering back in 2013.
it was started and i think 2006 is when
twitter became a thing
and it wasn't until 2013 until they
released their ipo
and became public
to get financing is the reason why they
went public
is to increase the size of their
company instead of going to a bank
they went the route of an ipo and
released public stock to buy parts of
their company
oh man
three weeks we're doing this elon musk
twitter blue balls [ __ ]
really is [ __ ] dumb
because elon musk and and again it's the
media the media out there oh [ __ ] he
bought it he didn't buy twitter yet
folks they accepted his bid
for the 44 billion
they accepted his offer
for the 44 billion he still has not
bought it yet there's a lot of [ __ ]
regulation and red tape to walk through
to take a company from being a pr a
public company like twitter is to being
a private 44 billion dollar
private corporation
and they have to follow all the laws all
the rules all the regulations they have
to do all that [ __ ]
again he's not gonna walk into the
twitter headquarters
with duffel bags full of 44 billion
dollars and they just hand him the keys
and they all walk out
give me a [ __ ] break
it's really dumb
it's really dumb good morning to all of
you
all you commenters out there minus
margie debbie from salt lake forest from
facebook here is here amanda's here
minus robin's here kimberly's here uh
patty vicki
janie cindy nancy patricia you guys are
all here good morning good morning mj
good morning mike snick is here
uh i i i i i'm forgetting a lot of you
crystal is here just because there's so
many of you in the comments
we appreciate all the new listeners
here at the tony michaels podcast we
broadcast live every single weekday
monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific
depending on where you are in the
country
or around the world really we have world
viewers believe it or not
and we broadcast live on our youtube
twitter and twitch page
so just go type in at tony michael's pod
the tony michaels podcast tony michaels
podcast on youtube twitter twitch
follow subscribe
and also we broadcast from the midas
touch facebook page i don't know if you
guys know that
midas touch
we are proud partner minus touch and we
broadcast from their facebook page we
are on the books of face so if elon musk
destroys twitter we'll go i i don't know
everyone's like oh i'm gonna leave
twitter and i guess uh um i don't i know
his name i think it's talcum x he's a
rapper is that right i i've never heard
of
i think his name is sean king i've never
actually heard of heard of him before
uh
i don't know i i'm not steeped in pop
culture but i i i don't know him but
apparently he already turned his account
off
and of course the right wing's cheering
because he left but i mean i don't
understand
what that means
i mean you left even though elon musk
doesn't own twitter and they're happy
that he left even though elon musk
doesn't own twitter yet it really is
[ __ ] dumb
does it does everybody know that elon
musk doesn't own twitter yet he doesn't
own it yet
it's not his yet he doesn't he's not
running [ __ ] over there yet
it's still the same twitter police that
was before
it's not the elon police it's still it's
still the same [ __ ] that it was
yesterday
all they did is say hey that 44 billion
dollars that looks like a nice stack of
cash that's that's basically what
twitter did yesterday
is that looks like a nice stack and i've
been getting a lot of [ __ ] you don't
know how this works you don't know how
that works elon's buying it tony
doubt me
doubt me i'm not saying i'm right or
wrong i'm i'm predicting that the deal
falls through that's actually what i'm
predicting i think the deal falls
through i don't think i think the media
is getting all hyped up everyone on
twitter is getting all hyped up and
that's exactly that's exactly what elon
musk wants that's what he wants
that's what he's here for is to punk
your dumb ass
come on
that's what i think
uh lisa says sean king is a social uh
activist tony yeah that that may be true
i i haven't heard of sean i might have
heard of sean before uh stumble crossing
but when i seen the name this morning i
didn't recognize it i didn't recognize
it i think it's i think it's a really uh
a dumb move
if he is an activist to not have a
microphone um you guys know
uh back when the joe rogan n word
controversy happened a lot of people
especially podcasters were were
boycotting spotify they were taking
their content down on spotify i will not
i will not
cower away from right wingers or nut
bags like elon musk i will not cower
away from them
if if really what he wants is freedom of
speech which is all [ __ ]
it's all bull he wants his freedom of
speech not everyone else's is what elon
musk means
let's face it
but i'm not gonna cower away from you
i'm not gonna cower away from spotify
i'm not gonna cower away from twitter
i'm gonna stay here and i'm gonna fight
that's what i'm gonna do
i'm gonna be yelling and screaming until
the microphone they're gonna have to
drag me out of this hell hole to get me
off twitter or damn sure elon musk is
gonna have to grab me by the short and
curlies and open my uh open the door
with my head that's the expression
telling you calm down everybody he
doesn't own twitter yet and he's a flake
he's a flake let me prove it here let me
prove it
i'll give you proof
i want to show you proof this is this is
proof that he's a flake
i know this seems trivial
but this is true here's a picture of
elon musk
with a haircut look at this here i'll
make it bigger
he flaked on his haircut this is not a
finished haircut he did not even let he
did not even let
the barber finish his haircut look at
this guy
does this look like a guy that finishes
anything
come on
give me a break
give me a break
oh
oh here brad brad's upset
brad ford is upset he said unsubbed
apparently i'm stupid eat [ __ ] if you
stay on twitter you're part of the
problem bye brad see you later dude
look if you're if you're upset about
speech
my speech especially if you're upset
about my speech especially well goodbye
see you later sayonara even brett says
adios goodbye
really this is dumb this is dumb
if you're gonna leave twitter then leave
[ __ ] it leave
go where where are you gonna go you're
gonna go to facebook oh you think you
think facebook isn't run by a
knucklehead
you think the metaverse isn't run by a
[ __ ] knucklehead
oh tick tock oh that's much better over
there go over to tick tock what about
instagram yeah you know facebook owns
instagram can't go there where you gonna
go you're gonna go to parlor
you're gonna go to get her you're gonna
go to true social get the [ __ ] out of
here with this [ __ ] come on get real get
real folks
pluck your head out of your ass and
realize
realize that elon musk has not bought
twitter yet
he's not i'm predicting that he won't
that's right everyone's like oh he's
he's bought twitter he's bought it it's
a deal it's not a deal they just
accepted a bid
this is going to take months and months
and months to put this deal together and
this guy here on the screen well that
guy right there that guy right there
who couldn't sit for an entire haircut
and flaked on his barber here huh
flaked on his barber
this guy
this guy
isn't going to flake on this deal come
on he's pumping you he's punking and
maybe maybe um
jay says i'm still in denial
i'm still in denial which i mean that
may be that may be i i may have this
delusion
that that elon musk doesn't flake on
things but he does he's been proven to
he said a lot of things that he was
gonna do and really frankly i'm kind of
pissed off about the 44 billion dollars
i am i'm really [ __ ] pissed off about
it here's why do you know do you know
what 44 billion dollars would do
for children
in schools do you have any [ __ ] idea
what 44 billion dollars could do to feed
hungry people in this country do you
have any [ __ ] idea
that's what we should be pissed about
that we are not taxing this [ __ ]
into oblivion
that's right if elon musk can afford to
buy a public company for 44 billion
dollars we should tax the ever-loving
[ __ ] out of him
that's what we should be pissed off
about this morning
if you're gonna be pissed off about
something don't be pissed off about he
owns twitter be pissed off that we
didn't tax him enough that that
[ __ ] can buy a private company
for 44 billion dollars
this guy can just [ __ ] out 44 billion
and he's bitching on tv on interviews
about us taxing him
get the [ __ ] out of here with that [ __ ]
so if you want to go
go
unsub leave i don't give two shits and
if you think i'm gonna give a [ __ ] and
not give my opinion on something your
your mistake you are in the wrong
[ __ ] place if you think i am
not gonna give my opinion on what i
think about politics or the social and
economical
position that our country's in
you have not been around long enough of
the tony michaels podcast you have not
that's for goddamn sure
if elon musk can afford to buy twitter
for 44 billion dollars
if that's if he can afford to buy
twitter for 44 billion with a [ __ ] b
he can afford some goddamn taxes
he can afford some goddamn taxes and he
can afford not to [ __ ] about taxes
especially when he his entire [ __ ]
electric car company was subsidized by
our tax dollars
hours
so
if you don't like what i have to say or
if you think i'm not gonna give my
my opinion and my commentary
you are
you are highly mistaken because we got a
lot of [ __ ] to get to today there seems
to be some news
um in ukraine
uh also
um let's see we've got news
oh the howard oh breaking news howard
stern comments on johnny depp
uh fidelity also has news uh dr burks
gives an interview i'm sure we'll watch
that clip
um jeff bezos is trending and tax the
rich is trending hmm i wonder why
i wonder why also
also ivermectin is trending oh [ __ ]
everyone thinks elon musk owns
owns twitter in a day and ivermectin
starts to trend of course
of course
of course that's what we got
it really is it really is it did
we live in the land of stupid this
timeline is so jacked up
it is our timeline is completely [ __ ]
someone at home office
please unplug the national timeline
and plug that [ __ ] back in
elon musk
elon musk is gonna buy twitter for 44
billion and they come to a deal and
everyone thinks that he i i don't
understand it
how the news yesterday you read the news
yesterday and thought that elon musk
owns it today
oh
man and the right wingers you should see
the right wingers on twitter man they
really do elon musk is like he's running
the show now he he took the entire
headquarters of twitter put it on his
laptop and he's running around his
friend's couches and boy he's just a
type it away
just a typing away and he's running
twitter from his laptop
speaking of tech geniuses we have our
local tech genius here
co-host and executive producer gabe
zinges
gabe i am i
we had we had a person unsub because
they don't like my opinion on elon musk
and they think uh they think it's crazy
that i'm not going off twitter so
they're gonna unsub our channel i'm like
look dude if you really if you really
want to censor yourself and you really
want to not have the speech that you
have regardless of how limited it may be
or who may limit it which
twitter already has a term of service
people and that terms of service will be
in place it may change
but it is in place it will remain in
place
elon musk will own the corporation who
owns twitter that's what will happen and
that corporation will have to follow
state federal all the walls that are out
there am i right gabe or is this just
going to be the wild west
now yeah see see that i called you a
tech genius but
yeah no no
no no it our local tech gene apparently
elon musk has cut our local text genius
oh man they're trying to get there
honestly this is this is big tech
silencing my speech right i know i know
you should you should definitely you
should definitely
kill your account and and cut your
internet access i am it's what you
actually need right now right you should
just delete your internet access that
way you know you don't have any speech
at all that's what you should do right i
don't here here's my take on this people
are like really upset about elon musk
find twitter right which is hey listen
we allowed this to happen right and that
being said
it's because we allowed ourselves to
create billionaires
i think where you're going with this is
where i was it 44 billion is a lot of
[ __ ] money and if we would have taxed
elon musk or jeff bezos into oblivion he
would not have the opportunity to buy
twitter
right i mean i mean both of those for
example both of those people made
tons an exorbitant amount of money
during covid okay like they they
i forget what the uh how many i'm sure
none of it was american pac taxpayers
dollars yeah no totally for sure
a lot of people are also coming out they
argue like oh elon musk paid the most
amount of money in taxes last year it's
like yeah because he's sold [ __ ] [ __ ]
stock right like
it's like when you sell like if he had
you know obviously he's got you know
capital gains or whatever but if you're
going to sell stock to take albert onto
cash you're gonna have to pay money on
that you're gonna pay taxes some people
like oh we paid the most yeah yeah last
year but let's go back in time jeff
bezos is the same way others who are
billionaires who don't take the uh who
don't pay taxes because they're not
taking out money right
like
it's one of those things where people
are like oh what about what about it's
like no we're not gonna play this what
about game it's like when i tweeted
yesterday uh i said you know elon musk
to everyone uh screw world hunger i'm
buying twitter and people got really
upset at that like i've been seeing that
tweet just kind of blew up because
people were like well that's not exactly
what happened you know uh he was told he
would get six billion to solve uh world
hunger and and my tweet says to help
fight world hunger i never said he's
gonna solve it i said one where you talk
about the flint thing too
that was another tweet that i did uh but
like i specifically used again
i don't here's the one
i'm thinking about right right so i use
my language very carefully here i never
wait wait you mean you mean you monitor
your own speech you piece of [ __ ]
i gotta i gotta let i gotta let the
beast out man i gotta let it go i know
so in this example in this example right
here right okay so for context for
anyone because i had people who came at
me last night and and during the day
they were like you never said this you
never did this you could literally like
you could save yourself time if you just
type this into google or duckduckgo
whatever the [ __ ] you use
instead of
commenting
and then posting and then getting told
by people that he never did or he
actually did this so in this example he
said a few years back when you know the
flint water crisis is still a thing it's
not as much of a thing but still a thing
and during it he said he would solve the
water crisis in any house okay right he
said he would basically redo the water
lines because that's really the issue in
michigan right
they they solve the water problem like
where it's coming from and the treatment
of it but they can't solve the pipe
problem for all the houses because it
cost money right
so he said i
publicly he committed in a tweet he said
i commit to solving flint's water crisis
in any house
instead
he just did a water filtration system
for schools now that's not a bad thing
that's a good thing yeah i'm not saying
this i'm not saying it's not a bad thing
it's good however
i had people came out there was like oh
well uh he he did a water filtration
system i go that's great during the
school year but kids have to go they
start their morning before they go to
school and they end their day when
they're at home outside showers they're
they're they take showers they they
drink they use water to cook they're out
of school
yeah they're out of school during the
summer and during breaks so what are you
gonna send the kids to the school to go
get fresh water like this is one of
those things where it's like yeah it's
great however it's not exactly what he
said then the other situation was when
the thai boys got trapped in the cave he
said he was going to go he sent his team
down to go to go uh fix the situation
and save them out of the cave he was
going to use a little submarine turns
out it didn't work and elon musk is not
the genius that everyone thinks he is
and so then instead he called this
british cave expert uh a pedo guy and
that's what he did and there was just
because he [ __ ] up because right
exactly yeah and the cave expert's like
oh it's actually going to work and then
instead of because elon doesn't like
being called out as a dumb ass uh he
instead decides to attack this guy and
call him a pedo which called a bunch of
issues uh i think there was even a
lawsuit that the cave expert took
against uh
uh elon musk for defamation i don't know
what the um resolution was on there but
i know there was a lawsuit and then most
recently he said that he would uh
because he asked a poll on twitter and
he said hey
where could i put my my money to to its
best use
to uh to contribute the most amount of
good and people said oh hey you should
solve world hunger right or help fight
world hunger and he's like okay how much
would that cost and some people had some
analysis online new york times cnn stuff
like that and it was 6 billion and and
it was for like i i forget the amount of
time maybe a year or so
and again what i said here was help
fight world hunger i never said we were
going to solve it because that's a whole
there's a whole we don't solve it that's
the pr that's the problem with hunger is
it's an ongoing exactly yeah you're
going to be hungry right tomorrow right
but right and for this like many things
there's an infrastructure that you would
have to build to make this sustainable
instead of just throwing money on the
problem and then saying great it's
solved again this is to help fight world
hunger whether that's actually directly
feeding the people that are in uh
the the mouths that needs to go into or
setting up some sort of plan or
infrastructure on how we can make this
work right but instead
he goes no i'm not going to do that and
then spends 44 45 billion to buy twitter
so i had people who were like you never
said that you never did that it's like
literally you could just search this
online it's very specific
you could take copy the text and paste
it in copy and paste very easy because i
know that these people who are
complaining me always copy and paste
someone else's thing that's set online
and then paste it as if it's their own
knowing not
just don't know anything about what
they're talking about so what they do is
they just copy to say oh yeah ivermectin
actually does work and then they paste
it into some comment and then they have
no rebuttal when someone says where'd
you get that how do you know that's true
do you have the actual
article exactly well so and i i like
your last line eli is not the savior
that he you think he is because here's
the thing
here's the thing about these these maga
these trump humpers out there loving
elon musk that he's gonna buy twitter
right
like literally if you were so excited
about elon musk buying twitter to fix it
he could have bought true social trump's
trump social media website for pennies
on the dollar
and he could have invested 45 billion
dollars into that social media here's
the thing the reason why elon musk is
not doing that is because
because
twitter is the [ __ ] social media
giant it is and it will remain that way
that's why he's buying it that's why he
didn't buy true social because trump
sucks and also if elon musk thought he
was so [ __ ] smart and so [ __ ]
genius
he would have created his own social
media platform
it could have been the social media
right it's the same people who
were upset about um
about a flight restrictions saying you
had to wear a mask or or show
vaccination status or whatever it is
that you were required to do when you
were traveling and these republicans
especially here or these republicans in
the u.s were like oh you know what we
should start our own airline and you're
like
okay if you want to do that go for it
however how hard it is to start an
airline right not only that but then if
if the airports are the ones that are
making you follow these these uh these
protocols well it looks like you have to
build your own airport too which means
that you'll have to buy hubs here and
here and here and here or or you mean
you're gonna have to have one in chicago
new york uh dallas uh yeah la you mean
here seattle you mean yeah kansas city
saint louis
yeah my god that's that's a that's a lot
of money that's probably more than and
then you gotta get five billion exactly
and then you gotta get the planes to fly
there and you're like well i'm not
buying 737s i'm gonna have to buy
probably private jets because there's
gonna be smaller airports i have to land
into
and also i've got to make sure that the
cost of people traveling actually makes
sense which i'm not going to probably
find that many people gabe you and your
goddamn common sense god damn you just
you just start thinking about stuff and
writing it down on a sheet of paper and
boy before you know it your woke ass
just destroys every every delusional
idea that you could possibly come up
with this is [ __ ] ridiculous that's
how i wake up in the morning you know
i'm asleep and i'm like i'm just like
loosely kind of in lucid lucid dream
stand i'm just writing stuff down and it
eventually wakes me up
right well you know that happens the
more important thing here i think that
you know because we talked about this
yesterday that because when we were
talking yesterday elon musk uh the deal
that he had uh offered to twitter they
had not uh officially
took the bid which that is the news he
didn't buy twitter yet they accepted his
bid that they offered yeah there's all
the six
or so months till like this is final for
elon musk to flake which is right he
gets the opportunity and he wants to he
certainly will again he can't even sit
long enough for a barber to finish his
haircut how do you think he's good jesus
christ he flaked on his on his barber
with his haircut here's here's the thing
though and we talked about this
yesterday the most important thing about
this transaction if it does happen or if
it's just this punking that that elon
musk may be doing on twitter and all of
us out here
is that
2 30 uh section 230 really needs to be
really reevaluated and of course maga
lost their minds to yesterday because
jinsaki said yeah the president wants to
relook it at 230 and see what reforms we
can have what a lot of people don't
realize is section 230 that was written
in the early 1990s almost 30 years ago
and everyone's like oh my god now they
want to reform it well here's the thing
congress actually did reform it
in 2018. they reformed it with a
different um act the sex trafficking act
that they passed in 2018. they reformed
230. um so
and and if everyone don't know doesn't
know
section 230 of the dca i think it's um
or uh it's is it cda or dca
communications cda community
communication decency act section 230
basically uh gives immunity to a website
that would post third-party content
right just like twitter or facebook um
you know it it
limits their liability now
there are certain things that don't
limit their liability again like the
the sex trafficking act i forget the
exact name of it that was passed in 2018
that reformed and changed 230 it added
to it so there's certain federal laws
and things like that that they are and
if they break federal laws then they're
not immune but
just because
it is a good idea for us to look at 230
doesn't mean that somehow oh my god see
they're tucking tail and running i think
i think back in october
um
beau of the fifth column had posted jin
saki's uh a press conference she had
back in october where she was talking
about the president united states and
the administration wants to consider
reforming section 230. they think social
media
needs some reform we haven't had reform
of 230 since
really 2018 but really before that in
the 1990s i mean we're 20 years
and the other thing too about this that
is most important about 230 and this is
where i want you to comment gabe is it
is so important
when we talk about 230
that us pro-democracy people out there
the people who believe in democracy
understand why it is so important for us
to elect
policy makers
not social media influencers because
most of these people and you go look at
these tweets on t-30s these people's
tweets on section 230 is [ __ ] dumber
than the [ __ ] tweets on ivermectin
like literally they have no idea what
what the [ __ ] this is and the problem is
some of those people want to be asked
for their aspiration is to be policy
makers and they are [ __ ]
they just have no clue about 230 and
about the the actual mechanics of how
230 would work if you did reform
well also the other thing that people
need to realize is that you know trump
in 2020
threatened that this was during the
election right right in the election to
change 230 to uh limit the amount of
protection that was offered
for these companies online right which
would hurt elon musk uh right crews
saved for free speech exactly because i
mean like you look at these places and
he's like oh well you know like
obviously before he got banned but
you know uh putting that as a as a
counter measure to say like hey listen
if you don't do this then i'm not gonna
or i'm gonna rewrite the rules here or
propose new rules on 230 so that it
limits the amount of protections that
internet companies have now i think like
bill gates even said like if we don't
have 230 then that would be like the
death of the internet you know in terms
of passing that kind of responsibility
off to those companies well i i and i
think i think the administration isn't
talking about axing 230 they're talking
about actual real and that's what i'm
the point i'm trying to make is if we go
out and actually elect policy makers who
who are very very very very smart and
they want to get
things like section 230 correct
for the american people and for the
world because that is important can you
imagine trying to explain 230 to lauren
bobert can you even [ __ ] imagine
sitting down and trying to explain to
her what 230 is and and and trying to
trying to have a conversation about what
kind of reforms she want from from 2 30.
can i [ __ ] imagine
i have a
hard time
thinking that she would understand what
decency meant or means you know in terms
of just like saying like all right so
there's the d i mean
she hasn't really cd yeah yeah exactly
right like yesterday she tweeted like uh
when
when does twitter get a new ceo or yeah
when does twitter get a new ceo
and i'm like
are we
i'm
look look i i don't want to rag on the
ged or anything like that but holy [ __ ]
this person really gives people who have
dropped out and taken the gd ged a very
yeah right because there are a lot of
people that are that are not boned right
exactly have to drop out of high school
for whatever reason pass their ged go to
college become very successful yeah
they're not they're not boneheads this
one in particular [ __ ] and bonehead
lauren boba really does a great job of
doubling down every single opportunity
she gets and then you know whether it's
you know lieutenant corporal
or it's
asking dumb questions about you know
who's gonna be ceo or giving her
customers the shits by giving them pork
sliders you know i just feel like she's
not competent enough right the same
thing goes for marjory taylor green who
goes up there and says i don't i don't
recall anything about saying martial law
then a text come out that she said
martial
law not actual not not like as in mark
like like
is she talking about like slim shady
like that right like the music company
like
yeah exactly
so yeah anyway republican party is full
of idiots but uh
this is something where it's like yeah
reform can be a good thing for for 230
especially since it was created in 1996
which was the [ __ ] beginning of the
internet when we were still being like
what does the at symbol mean right right
what is that exactly what is this email
you speak of is it like a fax machine i
mean literally
20 26 years later
and we haven't really made any real
substantial changes to modify like if
the internet is this ever growing
organism that evolves and adapts to its
surroundings and in other kind of
uh constraints that are put in place
like
our laws and our policies should do the
same so that we're not left behind and
that somebody can take advantage you
know right and we we don't have to we
don't have to send messaging on any
certain policy like no politician out
there should be running on 230. but us
as pro-democracy people we should be
electing people who are smart enough to
figure out what 230 is right i mean
literally
sarah palin is running
in alaska again
that but i mean she's the original she's
running she's running for or away from
something well i mean you know there's a
lot of different types of running with
sarah palin but the point is
the point is is that is that
it it could be a possibility that the og
dumb [ __ ]
uh comes into congress again and she
competes
and i mean coming to the conversation
right right right conversation you know
because right now all she can do is be a
social media influencer but that's what
marjorie taylor green is that's what
matt gatz is um yeah we've seen madison
gawthorne holy actual [ __ ] i you know
what i you know what people are saying
gabe about madison gawthorne a lot of
people i've said this over the weekend
they said that he likes to wear women's
lingerie they said i
i don't
i don't know that's true or not but they
were a lot of people were saying i i
heard he also sent out a statement oh
did he
yeah oh where is that at where is that
statement at uh i think we we shared it
yeah let's see let's see if we can find
that
why why why we're talking here but this
is why it's so important to talk about
this and to make sure we know um the
policymakers that we are we are electing
but we're not just electing boneheads
because they you know they've got oh man
they really got a good social media
presence and they can they can tweet or
whatever if they're [ __ ] smart that's
why you should engage in politics well
the same i mean yeah exactly i mean like
to say before we jump into this like for
the same thing that we'll say about uh
you know these idiots who don't
understand 230 or whatever it is like
these are the same people who are
pushing alternative methods of treatment
for covid right yeah and we're going to
get into that today yeah and it's like
you look at that and it's like these are
the people you know also who were making
money
on uh on pharmaceutical companies and
medical companies because they had
inside you know insider
trader knowledge right of what was going
to be happening who was going to be
they're not held accountable to that
right exactly and i think across the
board you know this is legislation
that's been introduced and i think it
should be uh it should be something that
is put in place and on both sides of the
aisle no one should be using their
political office for it to it to to
benefit themselves financially and the
problem is
all of these boneheads all these [ __ ]
idiots do that and they're not even that
smart they're not even that intelligent
they just found an easy loophole and
took advantage of it because some other
person said hey listen if you do this
thing and you got this information you
could totally trade on it you know like
these are the people that are deciding
our laws if they're taking advantage if
these idiots
are taking advantage of of loopholes
that we have in our laws
then then we need to one change them and
modify them like 230 or into one reelect
and put new people in power uh that
actually have our best interest in mind
or who aren't [ __ ] complete idiots
right well i mean democracy is the main
key here too you want a pro-democracy
candidate now the problem is in our
country right now is we only have one
choice of a party and we it's been a
while that that's been happening um you
know they always then veiled their
fascism with conservatism which is all
[ __ ] you know oh no taxes and low
taxes and t all that [ __ ] that's all
thin veil fascism um but really at this
point in our in our history we only have
one party that's pro-democracy in this
country and only one party that's that's
willing to work to hold our democracy
and our republic together um speaking of
bone ed's not willing to hold our
democracy together here's a statement um
gabe why don't you read this for our
viewers as if you wrote it like if you
wrote yeah yeah i don't know i don't
know why i would write this right yeah
uh
i would like to address the photos of me
that have recently surfaced online this
is just a desperate attempt by the left
to humiliate me but since they
intentionally did not provide context i
will these photos were taken while i was
a passenger on a royal caribbean cruise
with my close friends in the photos i'm
wearing women's lingerie because i was a
contestant on a game show or on a game
during the cruise that's it
clearly the left is running out of
things to throw at me in fact this
exposes them for what they really are
hypocrites
they claim to be for equality but will
happily attack me for wearing women's
clothing a man should be able to wear
whatever he wants without feeling judged
or ashamed and as a christian i live by
this so at this time i ask that you
stand firm with me and not step down to
their level
congressman madison cawthorne
all media inquiries go to luke
madisoncothern.com
[Laughter]
you should have read that last part
really fast
yeah yeah yeah you know so so where did
we find this this statement because um
uh matt as everyone knows madison
gothorn may or may not have been um
shown in a picture
over the weekend which we missed this
yesterday but i want to go to it because
which was friday i think it was friday
it was after after the hearing yeah it
was it was wasn't it and then
uh all of a sudden you know we were
texting and then
well yeah we found out yes we found out
that this image had dropped and we were
like is that real and then politico was
like hey look at this photo
well you know the other thing too
here here it here it is
um
ignore the mickey mouse photo here
um
i found this is his groomer and a
christian conservative yeah okay
okay now obviously this is only one of
the pictures of madison gothard but if
you if you look in here now again there
is nothing wrong with a dude wearing
whatever he wants there really is
yeah and then the statement we just read
who it seemed to be written by madison
gather i'm not sure if it's uh it is
seems to be in support of men wearing
women's clothing right they feel
comfortable
in their true self right whatever that
might be right whatever
and i think i think uh the real story
here with this
is that um not just madison gothorn but
republicans in general are complete
[ __ ] hypocrites because the outrage
about him doing this
is i mean it was all like oh my god of
course this guy
is doing the exact opposite he's
projecting and doing the exact opposite
that the party's saying of course that's
on [ __ ] brand but you didn't see the
right wing losing their minds like oh my
god madison cawthorne is a groomer he's
trying he's trying to sexualize women's
underwear he's trying to sexualize a
royal caribbean cruise this is the i
mean you see none of that outreach no
totally not at all i mean like you look
at madison catherine he goes on the
podcast says like oh there are all these
drug fueled uh sex parties and orgies
that are happening in dc
and then you've got you know other
people in the republican party who are
like hey dude uh
don't say those things and macarthur was
like i'm going to talk to madison
cawthorne right madison cawthorne's like
uh you know i i said what i said and i
saw what i saw roger stone comes to bat
for him and says uh he's not backing
down he did see these things uh and i'm
sure roger stone was like i was the guy
who had the coke
he was he was the guy who brought the
party yeah he got that fresh powder you
know what i'm saying that primo powder
but you look at this and you and
everyone's like oh my god all these sex
drug parties they're all the democrats
out of the cabals i don't know baby
blood all this random [ __ ] right and
then you find out that uh madison
cawthorne is you know wearing women's
clothing again nothing wrong with that
but he goes on to be like oh well i was
on a i was on a cruise and it was a game
it was before i was elected blah blah
blah all this stuff
and the right is like yeah seems like a
totally reasonable excuse
totally legit like no one even questions
it you know it doesn't matter if it's
true or not but it's the projection that
causes everyone to say well what the
[ __ ] is going on here for the same
reason that republicans fox news oan
everyone else goes after democrats to
say oh these guys are are pedophiles
these guys are sex sex traffickers
they've got child pornography i think i
feel like it's every single day we find
a new situation or a new case of some
republican congressman representative
senator whoever it is on a state or a
national level who gets caught or busted
with trafficking pornography uh you know
texting underage people
uh it just it just doesn't doesn't end
it's every single day somebody new comes
out of the woodwork because they expose
themselves
and that's what it is it's a party of
projection it's the grand old projection
the gop
these [ __ ] just do it to themselves
they blame others but then behind doors
they're doing the exact same thing that
they accuse others of doing so that's
all it is and this is just another
example with madison cawthran and what's
called him i got you another example
there's breaking news
rand paul is a [ __ ] [ __ ] box that's
breaking news yeah well right um
apparently
apparently um rand paul has um let's see
let me read it here let me pull this uh
tweet up here
recount has it the clip even um senator
rand paul uh the quote is now uh
secretary anthony blinken secretary of
state anthony blinken is testifying in
the senate today uh about the
the aggressor that is russia in um oh my
god
rand paul says the countries that have
been attacked georgia and ukraine were
part of the soviet union since the 1920s
secretary blinken says that does not
give russia the right to attack them so
let's watch the clip here of
of uh
the bonehead rand paul
probably getting dunked in the [ __ ]
trash
by secretary blink which is not hard to
dunk um rand paul in the trash just ask
his neighbor let's listen
uh it has not attacked nato countries uh
for probably a very good you could also
argue the countries they've attacked it
here we go
uh it has not attacked nato countries uh
for probably a very good you could also
argue the countries they have attacked
were part of russia
well that
we're part of the soviet union yes and i
firmly disagree with uh with that
proposition it is the
fundamental right of these countries to
decide their own future in their own
destiny and not saying there's not but
i'm saying that the countries that have
been attacked georgia that is exactly
what you're saying you [ __ ] box and this
guy is propagating putin's message
from the seat of a committee hearing
this united states senator
in our senate chamber is propagating
putin's [ __ ] [ __ ] message about
how ukraine used to be part of the ussr
it's not anymore it wasn't the soviet
union is gone and ukraine has been a
democracy yeah not a perfect one but it
is a democracy and it is a sovereign
nation
so get the [ __ ] over it pluck your head
out of your ass and realize that rand
paul is fighting against democracy when
he's saying this [ __ ] yeah he is
propagating this is a dumb hill to die
on yeah
like to to go in and defend and be like
well
uh
justified they are russia right like i
don't know why i said like yoda there
but uh
russia
like rand paul's coming in he's like
yeah russia uh they're totally justified
to attack ukraine and anyone else uh
yeah because a hundred years ago yeah
because 100 years ago
they really they're like they they were
part of the ussr well regardless of you
know vladimir putin's desire to build
the ussr again or or the soviet union um
it doesn't justify
attacks now it's like going back and be
like well retroactively like they're
actually part of it they owned it like
they can do whatever they want with it
because it's theirs here's a good
example
here's a good example to give rand paul
and all you [ __ ] trump bumpers out
there and you moglidates
here's the example
california arizona and new mexico it
would be in texas it would be like
mexico saying we're just gonna take that
back that's ours it was ours at one
point that's ours how would you feel and
how would the united states respond to
mexico marching across the border and
committing war crimes to take back texas
arizona new mexico california the the
part that was mexico at one time how
would you [ __ ]
build a wall morons like that
again this is really [ __ ] dumb it's a
really bad take and the reason why it's
a bad take is because it's putin's lies
that are making their way into our
public record and again
i know it doesn't seem related but this
is why you have to focus when you're
[ __ ] electing your officials with
[ __ ] like 230 because rand paul cannot
be trusted to put his hands anywhere on
230. you cannot trust that [ __ ]
traitor if that [ __ ] traitor is
willing to propagate putin's message
inside our united states house or a
senate chamber
then he is willing to put putin's
fingerprints all over any other
legislation
100
100 and the fact that this is you know
again like you said on the record right
it's the same [ __ ] that you know when uh
matt gates was like i've got the
contents of hunter biden's laptop on
this thumb drive one
uh why do you have the contents of the
laptop on a thumb drive that you're just
joking around with two it has now been
verified that things were put onto a
laptop after the fact and three like
you don't have the actual original you
have something that was a copy of
something else so to say that that is
the actual contents or to say that it's
all bad in this in this thumb drive
you know would totally dismiss the fact
of like someone else doing something so
when i look at this i see this as
another thing where you know the gqp
throws in their
uh their voice to
you know um
do disinformation or spread
uh spread disinformation within the
committee so it goes on the record to be
like well they they
you know he made a point for this it
wasn't a great point but he made a point
for this maybe we should reconsider this
right right well margie makes a good
point here rain approves uh england
taking back the u.s i mean yeah
and go all the way back right you know
but
give it back to the dinosaurs tony the
fact of the matter is it's what linda
from facebook says rand paul is a
russian asset absolutely 100 percent
um even kaelin points it out here john
mccain said it on the senate floor
pointed at rand ball john mccain when he
was still alive he pointed at rand paul
and said you're putin's puppet in other
words yeah i mean it just and and again
again this is why it's so important yes
yes yes elon musk my might by twitter
right but if we have certain policies in
place in this country and we reform 230
elon musk has his shortened curlies in a
ringer yeah because we do we are a law
[ __ ] nation we are a nation of
[ __ ] laws and we and now that they
don't apply to a lot of people right
you've seen the uh the the photo going
around of elon musk and um what's her
name just just lean maxwell oh yeah
jeffrey epstein's pimp or whatever she
was
um you know you see that picture i it's
someone almost mac is like oh no that's
totally fine dude right yeah oh yeah
well that's good that's good well you
know i i sir someone surmised that maybe
maybe elon musk
bought twitter for 45 billion dollars
just to scrub that picture off of
twitter i i don't know he's like he's
going to claim uh gonna claim like
copyright he's like that's my photo
right well you know it's kind of like
devin nunes when he took over at true
social they couldn't get it up and
running because he wouldn't allow any
handle to have the word devon and cow in
it
right or nunes and cow he just couldn't
have those combinations i mean devin is
also the guy who said there was uh it
that twitter was only a pr news wire
that there was nothing going on it was a
ghost town there wasn't a lot of
activity why would elon want to buy
something like that really honestly 45
billion i don't know that's crazy
let me tell you something that's the
other thing the other [ __ ] line that
i've heard is that twitter's not really
profitable and they don't really make
get the get get the [ __ ] out of here you
don't understand how stock and public
companies work then you're not you're
not understanding it you didn't watch
what happened to netflix if it is true
that twitter is not a profitable company
and won't be profitable those
shareholders will dump their stock they
will dump it and which would take it
into the [ __ ]
the same way as netflix discovered that
streaming may not be as profitable as
they say it is right it may not be and
and you're bound to have ads on your
netflix app coming in
in the next couple years because because
it's profitable
see that's what it is and and again the
only reason why elon musk would make the
decision for 45 billion dollars to buy
twitter is because it's profitable he's
not the smartest guy in the world but
he's smart enough to know that kind of
[ __ ] exactly and he's also you know
there's some you know there's been some
things that have been proposed whether
it actually happens or not you know
everyone wants the edit button okay fine
you know but there's also talk of
verification
right and verification meaning like
you'd probably send a photo uh
like it works on any other kind of app
or you take a photo of your your license
or your id or something and they say
okay great you're a real person now in
some ways i'm like yeah cool sounds good
to me because what it would do is it
would remove all the bots and there
would now be accountability
to anyone who said dumb [ __ ] right like
you made a threat you made an accusation
you know anything like that where your
account was in jeopardy because of
something that you broke against in
terms of service you would now be held
accountable to say well we now have your
information so either one you aren't
going to do that or two you are gonna do
that and we know exactly who you are
right so
in that regard i'm like yeah sure bring
it you know like i would i would happily
verify myself in terms of making you
know approving like proving who i am and
and who i say i am
um i can't say the same for others you
know obviously people on parlor who
decided to uh
to talk about the insurrection did
verify themselves by providing
documentation that they were who they
were right and as a result you know they
made it easy to find no that's also not
to say that yeah i know but again i mean
these are the same idiots who wore their
work badges and took selfies and posted
on their personal accounts that they
were inside the capitol and they were
smearing [ __ ] on the walls they're the
same
same morons they're the same morons that
love that elon musk maybe may
may be buying twitter again they're the
same idiots who this morning were like
testing ivermectin ivermectin right like
they think that the decision was an
overnight flip of the switch and i said
it yesterday all these people who come
on and say oh you know twitter is now
owned by elon he's now going to give us
the free speech that we so rightfully
deserve and we have earned and all the
stuff
whatever
again
you do you do you feel like
these things happen immediately no right
at all
he bought it yesterday gabe he he woke
up this morning he didn't just
he didn't drive off the lot he didn't
just like buy it get the keys and drive
off the lot and he was like and now
you're the owner that is not how things
work right like maybe for a small
business but even then it's like you
still got to go through legal has to
approve the contracts and you've got to
have you know doj and others have to get
involved to actually like make sure this
isn't some sort of right scheme right
right like there are other there's going
to be a regulation in place right for
him to buy this entire company exactly
public company and who knows maybe
something in the 11th hour happens and
they say oh it's not actually going to
go through now that very well could
happen or he flakes or he flicks which
is a completely total possibility this
is stuff that's happened before with
other companies and other people so
right you know it wouldn't be unusual
here's here's um here's a video about uh
speaking of vibromecht and i think the
reason why i'm vermecting started to
trend is because these right-wing
boneheads are like look we can tweet the
word i've i've i've been tweeting the
word ivermectin since last summer and
everyone said you couldn't tweet it no
one said you couldn't share your dumb uh
dumb research that has been either faked
or unverified or proven wrong and
debunked you can continue to yell out
ivermectin into the ethosphere and just
be like hey ivermectin it works people
are going to prove you wrong and you
probably get flagged as disinformation
well here's here's a perfect example
remember when aaron rodgers took
ivermectin for covet after consulting
with joe rogan um someone made a video
here i'm not sure who this is but um
let's
let's play this video and then we'll
we'll talk about the the ivermectin
situation and how it is all [ __ ]
that you're censored because you're
spreading around ivermectin
misinformation thank you for calling
poison control what seems to be the
problem what are the side effects from
taking avermectin sir are you taking
this to treat covet 19 yeah you do
realize that you and other people
calling about ivermectin are clogging up
our lines when we could be helping other
people with real issues i don't care
what are the side effects well the side
effects include but are not limited to
drowsiness confusion visual
hallucinations tremors [ __ ] oh yeah
wait what it can cause uncontrollable
[ __ ]
sir if you're taking this because you
read a study please know that data was
fake well joe rogan took it and he was
cured of coven ivermectin is an
antiparasitic drug it doesn't work on a
virus that's just a big form of
brainwashing you bro merc who creates
ivermectin is big pharma even they said
don't take it well cova 19 is basically
like a parasite and ivermectin treats
parasites so this will obviously attack
covenant team no that's not how that
works and you know what never mind can
you hold on one sec sure hey
come listen to this yeah what's up sir
i've got you on speakerphone right now
can you tell me one more time what you
took for covid ivermectin wait people
are still taking that stuff but even
merc said not to take it that's exactly
what i told him hello can you help me oh
no we can't but you're about to go
through some [ __ ] so good luck oh no
of course the fart noises always gotta
have got it got it
you know i i said this morning because
we're going to play the carrie lake
video because that's the other reason
why ivor mechtin is trending because uh
carrie lake yeah said some dumb [ __ ] and
here's the thing like ivermectin works
for the intended purpose that is not
coven 19. right words
yes
and it is fda approved it is fda
approved these are all true things i
here's the thing i've given ivermectin
to my dogs when they had worms as a
puppy
and it treats your dogs had covered they
had covet well yeah now kobe doesn't
have any worms but yeah right right but
like i you know i i gave it to my dogs
or my my one puppy uh chewie that had
had worms when i adopted him and i
treated him and yeah he [ __ ] himself
who's like [ __ ] well yeah yeah he
[ __ ] the worms yeah
you clean it all out man it's crazy
right you shut the worms up
in this situation
kovat19 is not cured or treated or fixed
or or made better by
ivermectin
that's it just doesn't work that way and
it's been proven again and again and
again and again and again there was a
double-blind study
i saw i saw the the acronym ctr today
for the uh double like controlled uh
study wait and that's the same as crt
and i was i was debating i was like
someone's gonna confuse this and be like
this is goddamn crt god it's the libs
and i was like no it's ctr anyway but
yes again ivermectin
does not treat fix cure or anything with
covid it works worse or stupidity or
stupidity right like you would take a
placebo and you would have the same
effects you'd probably actually be
better off than taking ivermectin
because
carrie lake would still be dumb as [ __ ]
uh cathy thank you for the super sticker
here um we're gonna i'm gonna show you
the uh
everyone give kathy a thumbs up for the
super sticker by the way you need to uh
come subscribe to the youtube channel if
you haven't already because you can
participate in the super chat or you can
give a super sticker or a super chat
it's super fun
to do i don't i don't know is that the
is that the noise that we make i don't
know do you want to have you maybe add
music to that video yeah yeah i gotta go
yeah some some points add a little
little jingle sound effect um here is uh
the video of uh carrie lake if if for
anyone who doesn't know carrie lake is a
[ __ ] bonehead and uh she's running
for governor of arizona which is uh
whoosh there's gonna be a lot of
boneheads that vote for this bonehead
for arizona right right i said remember
when choking down ivermectin until you
[ __ ] yourself was cool like holy [ __ ]
listen to what she says now this is
i think she said this like yesterday or
the day before this isn't like she said
it last year when they were all on this
train this ivermectin train
they're still taking it listen to this
[ __ ]
out there to buy ivermectin and find
somebody who can prescribe it to us and
then beg a pharmacist to give it to us
listen to what she's saying she is
literally saying she's literally saying
they're not going to
because it doesn't
work right
the doctor's not going to prescribe it
to you because it doesn't work like not
only not only is there proof in the
pudding but there's clinical studies
that show this is all [ __ ] bogus this
covid or this this ivermectin coveted
[ __ ] is all bogus so she's asking for
you to beg your
doctor because that's what you're gonna
have to do you're not gonna be able
they're actually passing walls i think
i've seen something in michigan where
they're trying to pass laws to where
doctors have to consider
uh prescribing ivermectin for a
treatment like they like they're forced
they're compelled to consider even
though there's no
there's no evidence that it works the
doctor is going to be compelled talking
about freedom of speech and freedom and
capitalism right but here she is begging
telling you to go big your doctor and
beg the pharmacist because the
pharmacist is going to go wait why would
the doctor prescribe you because i don't
know if you've ever had this before but
sometimes
you'll go get a prescription by a doctor
and then the pharmacist is like no this
is the wrong thing for what they're
saying you have yeah like no no i just i
just give my pharmacist a bunch of money
underneath the table and it was like
unmarked bills in a manila envelope and
they pass you horse dewormer and they
give me whatever i want whenever i want
that's a good idea right yeah but no
this is dumb this is so stupid because
you're you're this woman is complaining
about not getting a drug that doesn't
work to treat covid and then saying that
they're being unfairly treated or
they're not getting the same rights or
access to to drugs that uh they should
be which is again this woman is not a
doctor this woman went to the facebook
ivermecton university she got her degree
there and decided to get her phd in
dumbassery and then decided hey you know
what i should now preach the same things
that i learned on facebook to these
constituents and tell them this is a
platform that i stand on which is i
should make pharmacists and other
medical professionals give me a drug
that doesn't work for a thing that it
isn't for
and then beg the pharmacist to exactly
well let's let's listen to the rest
i will say this i guarantee that in any
situation that is a social setting where
someone has like she has to encounter
with hospitality or some service
industry or anything
she is
she's a karen no offense to other
karen's out there but she gives this
this group of people this like white
woman entitled privileged i feel like i
should get what i asked for because i'm
just who i am type of person
that's who i feel like in any situation
if someone could find footage of her in
a social setting where she's like super
stressed out you know i guarantee she
would act that way well the other thing
too that i'll mention about carrie lake
uh is that um eaton schmidt the guy who
runs around harassing cancer patients
yeah
supporting her and she's a
big supporter of him let's finish to see
what other dumb [ __ ] again we don't
look away here at the tony michaels
podcast so let's listen to one other
dumb [ __ ] this person now listen to
the cheers in the room that's what
terrifies me the most about this
it works like matt i've taken it it's a
wonder drug and it's outrageous they
kept that from us and it was anthony
fauci i mean it's a wonder drug if you
got worms yeah like if you got worms if
you don't it'll get rid of somebody
it'll get rid of some [ __ ] worms yeah
i mean it will clear that [ __ ] out
wonderfully expel some worms from your
body jesus but listen to what she says
about anthony fauci listen to this they
kept that from us and it was anthony
fauci who kept that from us
i'm encouraging
any law any lawmen here and i'm talking
sheriffs i don't think it'll happen in
maricopa county but i'm looking for
someone tough like maybe sheriff lamb to
issue a warrant
for anthony fauci's arrest out of
arizona
and the cheers it really is [ __ ] it
really is dumb it really is dumb so
she's she's calling for law enforcement
agents to issue a warrant because
anthony fauci only one dude one dude and
this is this rand paul [ __ ]
we just watched rand paul propagate
putin's message
it's the same [ __ ] thing when rand
paul questions anthony fauci he rand
paul acts like anthony fauci is the one
who decided that
drug companies could not prescribe and
doctors could not prescribe ivermectin
for covid
that's that that is not that is not how
it is it's also amazing that somebody
who is running as a candidate
just issued
uh right her state's sheriff or a
sheriff to say hey you know what
go out and do my bidding you know what
that sounds like it kind of sounds like
a fascist it's like you know there was
like a ron desantis right but there was
a country over in europe like in the
1920s the 1930s there was a country over
there i i think it starts with a g i i
can't really remember um geometry
schmurd reich
right kind of kind of comes out germany
you mean yes yes there was a country
over there they kind of did some of that
same [ __ ] yeah
yeah you can't make this [ __ ] up that's
the that's the iver mechtin trend um
let's see what else we have trending um
let's see if there's any more breaking
news of course rand paul jumped to the
very [ __ ] top here i mean um how does
he not right right here is the here uh
wu tang for children has the actual clip
that we were talking about earlier i
want to watch this watch what john
mccain says about rand paul legislative
session
is the president
is senator from kentucky i
object objection is heard
this guy does nothing but object mr
president i don't know associated with
the conversation well i mean i mean he
no just like anything
he also objects to his neighbor kicking
his ass right i'm just saying you know
but you look at you look at anything
when you're like oh what are we doing
like what was the uh what was the c-span
uh the vote that was happening for uh
wasn't it
uh contingency jackson brown yes well i
mean yeah he was the only one left they
were waiting on him i don't know if he
was wiping his ass after he took a [ __ ]
or what but they were they were waiting
for i i don't know a good 10 or 15
minutes for this guy in to come in and
give it is no vote of course he was
going to vote no
but i mean i mean you know everyone is
always waiting for everyone no matter
what always everyone is always waiting
on on rand paul everyone right well
let's let's listen to what john mccain
says here
about his uh rand paul's objection
leaving the floor without justification
or route or any rationale for
the action that he has just taken
that is really remarkable
that a senator
blocking a treaty
that is
supported by the overwhelming number
perhaps 98
at least of his colleagues would come to
the floor and object and walk away and
walk away
the only conclusion you can draw
when he walks away is he has no argument
to be made he has no justification
for his objection
to
having a small nation
be part of nato that is under assault
from the russians so i repeat again
the senator from kentucky
is now working for vladimir putin
i yield the floor whoosh john mccain did
not mince words when it came to rand
paul there yeah um thank you uh wu tang
for um bringing that to everyone's
attention and posting that from um let's
see if he's
uh never forget the time john mccain
said rand paul works for putin i believe
this was um i i think it was in two
did do
it was during the
um obama administration i believe 2017.
yeah 2017. so it was no it was it was uh
after trump march 15th 2017. okay so
it's a recent history not ancient
history um let's see if we can find some
more clips of this [ __ ] bonehead
um
i don't want to play too many long clips
here of this this worm
you know what
if rand paul is a worm maybe we should
give him ivermectin i'm just saying i
mean go for it i mean it looks like the
things in his hair are worms right maybe
maybe he's got worms in his [ __ ] head
maybe that's the problem i'm not sure
i'm not sure if carrie lake is right
here gary lake may be correct in that it
would be a wonderful thing if i ever met
and did away with the worms in this guy
i've come to a point where
you know
last year
uh oh nine i i don't know if i sent it
but like nine months ago i had a tweet
that when all of this kind of came up
which everyone's like oh you got to take
ivermectin this is craig cure
and i was like
hey spoiler alert it's not right nine
months later to the day
right uh almost the 25th of july is when
i when i made the tweet and now we're at
april 26 like nine months later
the time it takes for a baby to
all the way through its process right
for a warm to catch
for a worm to hatch we have a study a
double blind study that comes out to say
that ivermectin doesn't do anything it
just proved what we all knew right it
had already been debunked in many ways
and now we find out that it has and i've
i've
i can't stop
but
like i can't help myself but only make
fun of these people because at this
point i'm just like you know what my
frustration and my attempt to kind of
like hey
don't do it don't be an idiot don't take
it you're just gonna [ __ ] yourself and
you're not gonna feel any better right
like anything you feel better might just
be a state of mind but actually isn't
gonna help you like health-wise and so
in this moment i look at this and say
i'm done i'm done you know what you guys
take this [ __ ] [ __ ] your brains out uh
don't cure covid like uh you know if it
means that you know this this uh this
herd of of followers has to uh has to
thin out because they took um
warmer sheepy warmer
than so be it i guess you know what it
you know if uh well we have a large part
of stupid population that definitely
doesn't have worms um speaking of morons
that don't have worms here is another um
section now this has posted this it's a
couple minutes long here but this
apparently is the back and forth between
secretary of state anthony blinken and
uh
wormhead ron rand paul um again
hopefully he's on his uh his daily
ivermectin dose and he can get the worms
out of his head understand that he's
propagating putin's messenger but let's
listen in you look at the countries that
russia has attacked uh over the last
years georgia
uh leaving forces in transnistrian
moldova and then repeatedly ukraine
these were countries that were not part
of nato uh it has not attacked nato
countries uh for probably a very good
you could also argue the countries
they've attacked were part of russia
well that
we're part of the soviet union yes and i
firmly disagree with uh with that
proposition it is the
fundamental right of these countries to
decide their own future in their own
destiny and not saying there's not
that's what i'm saying yeah you are
saying that and again this is part of
the same clip but this is the extended
version so this is the context before
and then we're going to get a little bit
after so listening that the countries
that have been attacked georgia and
ukraine were part of the soviet union
and that's where and they were part of
the soviet union since the 1920s but
that does not that does not give russia
the right to attack them on the
continent exactly it does but they
really are something i'm not saying you
are saying see this is that stupid [ __ ]
that i always talk about where they're
like oh well this thing is bad so the
alternative must be good right this is
the same russian putin-ass [ __ ] trumpism
[ __ ] that they do where it's like well
this thing is bad this thing is really
bad
can you even imagine gabe that these
countries used to be part of the ussr
they used to be russian communist
property how how could we not
recognize that there's that it's putin's
property here i'm not saying that but
i'm saying the alternative the
alternative must be nice like right
murdering innocent women and children
[ __ ] this [ __ ] traitor part of this
like
the same type of approach that he has
here where he's like oh i uh he's like
i'm not i'm not look i'm just saying i'm
just it's like you know it sounds like
tucker carlson being like oh well hey
listen i'm just an inquiring mind asking
questions you know like i'm not saying
that it is this way i'm just asking
questions and it's like no by you
bringing it up you're trying to use it
as an argument and you're trying to cast
doubt uh uh why ukraine should defend
itself you're trying to say that russia
is justified without saying that russia
is justified you're saying it like right
you're you're you're trying to use their
past on what they were and what they
were part of as a means of saying yeah
russia could totally come in and just
take what they want they can kill people
they can do genocide they can do
whatever they want because you know what
georgia and ukraine they were part of
the ussr
it's the same thing that that donald
trump did when when putin was going to
invade and he stood at his little
fundraiser where he was grifting so that
he so that he doesn't go broke and
apparently he's gonna have to pay ten
thousand dollars a day so it's a good
thing he's holding fundraisers because
he's gonna go broke fast doing that but
he stood there and said oh this is a
great real estate deal it's a great deal
for putin how how couldn't putin think
this is a good deal i mean he's getting
two dollars worth of sanction he's
getting all that land it's basically
what trump boiled it down
trump said he's a genius right yeah he
it trump does think putin is a genius he
does think that either that or he's
forced to think that let's listen to
what uh secretary blink and his rebuttal
hears
if you look at why
president putin went to went into
ukraine this time
we took very seriously
the arguments that some russians were
putting forward back last fall rand paul
concerns about ukraine's eventual
membership in nato in terms of their
security posture russia's security
posture what would this mean in terms of
the placement of forces near russia
weapons systems et cetera we sought to
engage them on those issues in real uh
seriousness as well as engage them on
deep concerns we have about many of the
things we do that undermine our security
but when
everything came to a head it is
abundantly clear in president putin's
own words that this was never about
ukraine being potentially part of nato
and it was always about his belief that
ukraine does not deserve to be a
sovereign independent country that it
must be
reassumed uh into russia in one form or
another and yet that is not yet the
discussion
and yet the discussions between
zielinski and the russians have included
discussions of them uh assuming an
unaligned or neutral posture so that has
been part of the discussion and this is
a sovereign decision for ukraine to make
right but at the same time we're all
over the place you know thinking we're
coming to the rescue
no no we are not that is all [ __ ] we
are not all over the place the biden
administration has stood with democracy
that is there they have stood with nato
they have stood with ukraine because it
is a sovereign nation and it is a
democracy for [ __ ] sake this is so
ridiculous again he's propagating the
whole putin message by saying oh this
bad alternative must be good and then
maybe sometimes we're not maybe
sometimes we're agitating for something
like admission there you go that makes
it see oh what what we're doing is bad
so we must have good meaning we got to
let putin do whatever he wants we have
to let putin do whatever he wants
because us getting involved is bad right
maybe ukraine has a more of an ability
to make this decision if they're not
being pushed and goaded by half the
members of the senate who want them in
nato so perhaps it is perhaps it is not
useful to be pushing them into nato and
perhaps they will come to an we are not
pushing them they want to be in nato
what the [ __ ] is he talking about what
is he talking about he wants the
protections this is so [ __ ]
ridiculous what a [ __ ] box rand paul is
i mean just a 100
total [ __ ] [ __ ] box speaking of [ __ ]
boxes it looks like uh caitlyn pointed
out some breaking news here um
how serious is this is this news gabe i
haven't looked at it yet
uh well according to this it says
madison catherine was cited for having a
gun at the charlotte douglas
international airport tuesday morning uh
three sources tell channel nine and
according to the tsa a nine millimeter
handgun was discovered at checkpoint d
tsa declined to identify the person with
the gun but we know who it is a photo
obtained by so at the time at the time
they denied or they're saying no they're
just saying that no no no no no they're
saying that three sources
that are you know uh
know of the situation said that it was
madison hawthorne they're saying that
according to say it was discovered and
they declined to identify the purpose
the the person
um
it was a loaded a foot obtained by
channel 9 shows a loaded staccato c2 was
recovered at charlotte douglas tuesday
morning this is the same guy who keeps a
knife in his wheelchair on the below the
seat
uh
and even told students that he had it
well the other thing dude this is the
same guy that was bragging um on film i
think it was at some kind of fundraiser
event or campaign event where he was
bragging that he had weapons on his lap
during the insurrection they brought
weapons inside the capitol
during the insurrections he had him on
his lap you know i don't i don't
remember the exact phrasing that he used
um
but he he said that um
um
patriot takes has a video of madison
culture i don't know if this has
anything to do with it let's let's watch
and see what patriot takes this is a
video that they have
again could you answer our question do
you feel president trump had a role in
what took place in stoking the anger
this is about january 6.
saying these falsehoods these things
that have been debunked repeatedly and
with many many people in courts saying
that the election was carried out fairly
and justly
uh yes so i i do believe that you know
uh but i do believe also that you know
the court systems the judiciary system
let us down in this election uh the
supreme court should have heard this
case
they did hear the case dummy
[ __ ]
to make sure that the constitution can't
be violated again in the future uh but
you know what after those legal needs
were used we certified the election it
appears joe biden is going to be the
president and i will support the office
okay number one um this guy has more
trouble with the microphone than you do
gabe jesus yeah i know
wow
i think he's not the producer on the
show right no [ __ ] i wouldn't let him
anywhere near production um and myself
you know maybe some other person would
but um i wouldn't but let's see if we
can find um here joe bruno has breaking
madison cawthorne was cited for having a
gun this morning this is this morning at
uh charlotte douglas right national
that's that's what this is about this is
morning so so that this is the link that
you sent me the link i sent you is the
wsoctv okay
that is board
okay so um so is this um are there
are they filing charges against him
uh
he says
he's being signed it's unclear okay it
says it's unclear if catherine will face
any criminal charge as a spokesperson
for the charlotte uh mcclendon
police department couldn't immediately
comment this is not the first time a gun
has been discovered on cawthron at the
at an airport in february 2021 tsa found
a nine millimeter handgun in catherine's
carry-on bag at asheville regional
airport cawthron did not face any
criminal charges for the incident
um
yeah it says spokesman for cawthorne did
not respond for a request for comment
so
again this guy is a repeat offender he
has weapons on him he thinks that he can
just walk wherever fly wherever with any
sort of weapon without any sort of uh
repercussion
he wasn't charged the first time i doubt
he'll be charged this next time because
it's in his home state
it's a local airport
uh you know he didn't fly with it he got
stopped with it i'm sure in that moment
it's just like anyone else who gets
stopped with a gun they go oh cause you
can you can bring a gun on an airplane
you just have to do it in a certain way
right and well i think you also have to
like you have to check the back right
you have to check right it has to check
your bag it has to be separate like
there's a whole right that's right each
airline might have a little different
procedure but like there's also um we're
talking about federal agencies here um
that allow you to fly because that's the
thing people really don't get right it's
like they allow you to fly in an
airplane these federal agencies um but
but there's but there's probably a
certain way that he has to right um i
mean there's a way you can't just leave
a loose gun
in your bag
but i think what's going to happen is
he's going to like marjorie taylor green
madison cawthorne's going to be like i
don't recall i don't remember i don't
know how that gun got in my bag i don't
know how it ended up there what he's
going to end up doing is he's going to
say oh you know what i totally forgot
because here's the thing he's not going
to get in trouble for carrying the gun
because he'll easily say oh you know
what i didn't even realize it was in
there my bad take the gun right and that
also says to how cheap it is to acquire
a gun because he'll probably you know
get a new gun get it registered if he is
registered at all uh he's probably got
more guns at his house but this is one
of those things where he's gonna look at
and say like oh you know what
i tried to get through security couldn't
do it they took the gun
no harm no foul on me
i'm not in trouble and i think that's
what's gonna happen again and i'm pretty
sure that's what happened the first time
is he never got onto the plane he was
never in a secure area he was going
through tsa and they stopped him and
they said hey there's a gun in the back
and he goes oh my god oh [ __ ] okay yeah
you could keep that right and i think
that's what's gonna happen well here's
here's what i just reminds i just
tweeted this where does madison gother
and stash his gun
i'm setting it up i'm setting it up here
folks you can knock it out of the park
go go knock out where madison cawthorne
and where does he stash his gun um so
we'll keep an eye on the madison
cothren's story jesus christ they never
let us down do they they never let us
down like no it's always and
the [ __ ] uh they don't know that elon
musk hasn't bought twitter it just it's
run and on every every moment of every
day is some
some [ __ ] dumb ass thing they do
and i mean this whole the party is full
of
idiots you know like i'm okay look i'll
say this democrats and republicans
they both have idiots but the republican
party holy [ __ ] you guys really do a
great job of monopoly i'm setting the
bar
real low like real low like i
i don't even know if i could get
underneath that bar anymore like it's
just like an inch above the ground
whether it's your sex trafficking or
pedophilia or carrying guns or trying to
throw over overthrow the government have
an insurrection like you name it
you guys are dumbasses they're there for
it man they are there for it and every
day they say
i can i can do one better we we can we
can make we can make our stupidity
even stupider you thought that was dumb
just just give me 30 minutes let me go
get my gun and go through the airport
speaking of uh trump stupidity do you
remember
um a time in this country when we had a
president who stood up
at a podium at an official press
conference where they were giving
briefing briefings on health and disease
issues at the time um do you remember
this guy he stood there and he said well
here let me i think i got a quick clip
here let me let me play it
and um and then we'll go to the the
trending topic here
oh no it's not going to play the sound
it just shows if you guys know this is
dr burke's this is when trump was saying
you need to inject bleach into your into
your veins do you remember this gabe do
you remember this this was i remember
that's when you throw a little light
into your body well yeah yeah yeah
figure out figure out how to get those
that uv light in your body i'm looking
for a damn video here of this interview
uh dr burks apparently gave an interview
and has basically said oh they i i
didn't know what to say i didn't know
what to say
when they were
spewing a bunch of lies and [ __ ]
yeah um
it's uh abc exclusive
and let me see if i've got it here yep i
think this is it here let's listen
uh pull it up here let's listen
maybe you're an immunologist
um do you think that we will be needing
a how don't they have this mic worth of
[ __ ]
what in the [ __ ] abc what the [ __ ] can
you hear the buzzing of the lights yeah
can you hear it
yeah yeah i was gonna say yeah
i have a mic it's ridiculous i'm close
and personal right they need to they
need oh jesus okay let's listen shot or
a booster every year
so here's the tricky thing remember i
said i've talked about how everybody's
it sounds like they're in a [ __ ]
bathroom or something yeah there is a
there's a definite echo in this in this
interview right now and it sounds like
you know it sounds like you know what
they're in
a um
like inside the body they're in like
they're in like one of those like um
demo houses like where they they're like
hey come through and get nice no
furniture no right yeah where they're
like get an idea of what the rest of the
neighborhood is gonna look along the
walls right it's like it's like a repo
or something right yeah yeah and then uh
you know it's like the house from uh
arrested development like it's kind of
just there's just like prop items it's
pretty echoey and everyone's helping us
out with the uh the quotes here
disinfected knocked it out in a minute
kevin yeah yeah and that's that's maybe
the quote um now aside from this genius
said that right the reason why i'm
bitching about the sound is because all
you out there listening this on the
podcast which again if you're not
downloading the podcast you should
on apple spotify and google
but all you out there listening to this
audio are going to be pissed off at me
but here's the thing me and gabe have
this new magic tool uh it's kind of like
ivermectin
on covid no not well actually it helps
with the audio so you guys are going to
see a little bit of a change in our
audio so make sure you go download
each episode of the tony michaels
podcast go ahead and download each
episode
um and give leave us a five star review
over there but again don't take in
account this audio this is not our audio
we're not taking credit we're not taking
responsibility just like right i don't
take responsibility nope nip not me not
me so let's let's listen into what dr
burks has to say about her capitulation
new response and their peak is different
you don't want to continually boost
someone that has a really high
antibodies okay this is not this is not
the clip that i thought it was this is
not the clip
dr burks has lost all credibility right
that she ever had
because of the moment that she let trump
is this it is this is the moment this is
one where she's like hey
she here he knocks it out
disinfectant
where it knocks it out
in a minute
one minute and is there a way we can do
something like that
she's like my life injection
or
almost a cleaning because you see it
gets in the lungs and it does a
tremendous number along so it'd be
interesting to check that so that so you
want to and he's
he's just having a conversation with her
he's like yeah yeah right right right
and she doesn't say anything to say no
which means that everything by hurt not
saying no or by her not kind of
correcting him uh everything he says is
truth everything he says is real right
again again again it goes back to the
the alternative must be true right if
this thing bad the alternative must be
true exactly so i'm providing you an
alternative
to the thing so it must be good it must
be good you want to drink bleach oh my
god but here's here i think this is the
clip here of her responding
now on on abc to that situation let's
listen there's a part in the book where
you you notice the audio is much better
in this clip yeah the other one was more
raw what the [ __ ] is going on i don't
know there's furniture in this house
here maybe that is let's listen talk
about your concern that
men at the white house might see you as
hysterical or
overreacting i love how it's only men at
the white house like she's like men at
the white house like no men in general
that's what men in general do to women
yeah like if if you're out there and
you're a man and you don't realize that
that's either what you're doing or what
happens that's what happens to women
they think oh you're getting hysterical
calm down there
let's listen
just because you were often the only
woman in the room
you are not a shrinking violet you have
a 29-year history of military service
you became a physician when there were
not a lot of women in our profession
usually people say to me
you're being too direct you're being too
pushy they'll often use the b word but
remember i've worked on pandemics where
people's lives are at stake and so i
feel like if you have to say things over
and over again and more forcefully each
time and really say we've got to do this
differently because this is what still
is happening
that is not being the b word that is
okay dr
burks
except i didn't hear any of that where
the [ __ ] were you during that press
conference when that [ __ ] was was
yelling into a microphone for people to
disinfect themselves right and disinfect
their lungs where were you that's what
people are pissed off about they're not
they're not saying they're mad because
the quote-unquote men in the white house
treated you like as an
hysterical [ __ ] because that's what
she's saying the b word is [ __ ] i can
say it here they can't say it on good
morning america but we can say it here
um
that that they were treating her like an
hysterical [ __ ]
be hysterical in that moment
save lives be hysterical
you know as doctors they all took oaths
to help
you know those who could not help
themselves right like it you know it in
many ways you could say it's the the
true christian way right the true way of
jesus christ for all those [ __ ]
hypocritical christians out there who
want to say you know help those who
can't help themselves and in this
scenario you've got trump who goes on to
live tv give a press conference early on
i think it might have been april or
something when he gave this press
conference and said yeah i believe it
was near the end of it yeah april april
2020 is when he goes on there and says
oh yeah disinfectant you know inject
some bleach knock it out and uh you know
you know in a whatever how many it was a
week yeah and he did it in a way where
he was asking her right and he's saying
he's like i'm not taking responsibility
right i'm only asking you tucker
carlson's style questions right he's
like you said right you you you agree
right we we had we just had a
conversation and in her mind she
probably was like no we never said any
of that we said there might be some
early developments of treating and
knocking out
this uh this virus using different ways
of like light but that's like light in
terms of on an object probably right not
on a human again they did say some of
this [ __ ] but he wasn't [ __ ]
listening because he's a [ __ ] box he's a
dumb [ __ ] and a buffoon they were saying
disinfectant kills it like on a surface
right the other thing the other thing
the uv light kills it like when it's in
air in a room right
not the same not the same uv light that
you use to tan your balls and be a man
this is different uv light that you use
to kill all kinds of germs right to kill
bacteria to kill a virus and this is one
of those moments you see in the you see
her in the video on another one where
she just goes
she's just sitting there she's just
sitting there and she doesn't say no you
know she doesn't say oh actually i meant
it this way or or she didn't even say
hey you know what actually i will go up
and i will explain this
as a medical professional as a doctor as
someone who is studying
who has studied viruses and pandemics in
the past actually you know what
i think it would be best if i just
explained this yeah it's a little like a
blow to trump's ego and maybe he would
let her talk or not but at the end of
the day it's like if you're someone and
you're hearing someone else totally
butcher
what they was what that he was just
explained
moments before this in their meeting you
should go up there and be like actually
huh i just want to tell you what we said
that's right and he's like i i want to
clarify a hysterical [ __ ] be hysterical
in that moment do that exactly
let's finish what she's saying saving
lives it's being direct and clear
um and i think this was unusual because
i was often painted as
pollyannish as
skipping around
saying that pandemic's not bad and it's
resolved um also by not saying anything
right the actual narrative to be right
very unusual again
do you know the reason my hyper megan is
trending today because this dumb [ __ ] dr
verts
dr burks did not get out in front and
say no stop saying that [ __ ] trump about
hydrochlorical and and all the other
[ __ ] boneheaded bogus cures stop
saying that [ __ ] and she should get in
front of she should have got in front of
the microphone and said no release
public statements from her official
office saying no i do not agree with the
president when he's saying these things
right so the idea that she that oh well
you know but she she came off as anti
anti-mask or you know and covid was over
you were because you weren't saying
anything when you [ __ ] know you know
the truth and you're not saying it out
loud she's capitulating to the lie again
it's the same putin propaganda the same
trumpism the same q and on [ __ ] that
this thing must be bad so the
alternative over here that i got for you
must be great even though you don't know
anything about it exactly and in this
scenario with dr burks you got to look
at and say if you didn't speak up and
say anything to the public right maybe
you said something behind closed doors
after the fact he said actually
president trump it means this that
doesn't do anyone any good because no
one's privy to those conversations so at
the end of the day by you not speaking
up and saying anything you're
you're complicit
in what is what is being what is being
uh inferred by trump right like he goes
out and says oh well the light will
knock it out and it'll do this and
doodle that and that's how you treat it
you can inject bleach like insane things
that you would never hear a president
kind of give as possible treatment right
or tried to push uh crazy bogus drugs
for kovid but then you have
uh dr burks right and i'm going to say
this you know dr fauci also someone who
didn't speak up during the conferences
as well when they were alive there were
moments when he gave kind of a
physical expression of uh of just like
holy [ __ ] what am i saying there's
several times that he did rebut when he
would go up and he would rebut exactly
he said right around as forcefully as
the american people needed in the moment
right yeah but looking at dr burks she
said she said nothing right like i look
at this and i say it's super easy
for her to now come out and say hey i've
got this book and this is my experience
and talk about it and try to re-you know
revisionist storytelling wait you mean
she's profiteering off her capitulation
is that what you're saying and she's
trying to reap not only she profiteering
she's trying to reframe it is that is
that
it would sure appear that way tony
well that happens that happens that
happens with some of these some of these
folks um we're going to take a quick
break right here gabe are you going to
stick around to the end of the show i
got i got howard stern that i want to
talk about all right let's do it
let's take a quick break we'll be right
back don't anyone go anywhere we're
going to talk about howard stern johnny
depp and amanda heard the story oh boy
being talked about all around the world
yeah we'll be right back after this
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
fellow patriots what would you do if
there was a trump supporter right in
front of you crying in pain because they
have to live under communist tyranny
we know what you would do you'd reach
out and give that true american a hand
now here's your chance for only 50
dollars a day you can help us help those
true americans recover from biden's
socialist reign of terror these are
those trump supporters and this is that
moment
send your donation via venmo to the real
president
donald j trump
it's only fifty dollars a day
recurring and it means you'll get these
trump supporters the critical help they
so desperately need to survive under
this false regime
please donate now because those trump
supporters you just saw
can't wait another moment
we're back to the tony michaels podcast
[Music]
welcome back to the tony michaels
podcast
[Music]
we're gonna talk howard stern here in a
minute
howard stern's been a broadcaster for a
long time
great
the great howard stern radio show host
they all think howard stern is woke now
he just woke up he just woke he's woke
he's so much so much liberalism in that
hair i know you know what you know
what's funny is that that um howard
stern is probably the furthest thing
from woke um i mean howard stern
probably has some common sense left
after you know he's been famous for
years and years from broadcasting
speaking of broadcasting did you know we
broadcast this show the tony michaels
podcast every single weekday
monday through friday
monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific so
if you're up gabe at nine o'clock if i'm
up at nine yeah i know you can check out
this show
we also not just from youtube twitter
twitch because those are our pages so go
go search the tony michaels podcast on
youtube twitter and twitch and follow us
in all those places but also we
broadcast live every single weekday
monday through friday on the books of
face what midas touch facebook page we
broadcast two hours two full hours every
single weekday monday through friday on
my facebook page as well and then you
know what's even crazier about this
is after we're done doing the live
broadcast you can actually download
you can download the episode wow on
apple spotify and google or anywhere
that you get your podcast
that's amazing
are you trying to do an orange stern
yeah no no no howard stern's howard
stern's more deep that was that wow wow
wow that's like that's a howard that's a
that's a i didn't know how i'm doing no
that's an owen wilson where he's like
wow oh yeah yeah wow wow that's amazing
wow wow amazing that's amazing so howard
stern is trending here
um and you see it's number 14. now it's
under entertainment
someone asked me this week just under
covid or
so you know at least that we're doing
better on the twitter trends right right
if you if if you look here
um ivermectin's 13 howard stern is is
14. um someone asked me this weekend
because i've watched a few of the clips
from the
amber herd johnny depp uh deformation
trial that is going on um i've seen some
memes there's a lot of stuff going
around and actually someone asked me i
think i was actually talking to them
about russian and ukraine over the
weekend and out of nowhere like in the
middle of our russia ukraine the
discussion they're like so are you team
are you team heard or team dipped i'm
like oh my [ __ ] god really this is
the [ __ ] this is the [ __ ] that is
concerning us right now yeah but here
howard did they try to make a connection
do they try to be like oh johnny depp is
this country amber out of this country
no just out of nowhere
they wanted they wanted maya they wanted
the fresh take from tony right right
they wanted my fresh take on amber heard
and johnny depp um which the radio host
howard stern
basically
kind of lays it out what his opinion is
here of course because that's what
howard a lot of people are mad that
howard stern gave his opinion on this
like what do you think howard stern does
what the how [ __ ] long have you not
known who's howard stern is or what he
does right like this is this is
literally what he does is give his
opinion
on hollywood type [ __ ] amongst other
things but more specifically [ __ ] like
this he's been doing this for what 40
[ __ ] years probably i don't know 30
years at least
howard's radio radio host howard stern
discussed johnny depp's live stream
defamation trial against his ex-wife
amber heard calling the actor a huge
narcissist
duh i mean obviously
it's obvious that
johnny depp is a huge narcissist
that is not real is that really up for
debate
i don't know the whole situation i'll
just say this like i don't know who is
the real
uh
victim or or uh
you know who the predator or or you know
bully in the situation you're talking
about you're not talking about the
howard stern thing you're talking about
and johnny depp like i you know like
she's abused uh
him there's photos you know obviously
i don't know it's a yeah i feel like
it's super super messy they're both
pieces
let's let's see it's incredibly messy
to put it on
tv i'll just say that right like well
but don't you think and the howard
stern's probably right here that johnny
depp
and i don't know if it's it is probably
narcissism but if you read what howard
said then we'll try to see if we can
find some of those those quotes he's
saying that johnny depp wanted this out
there like he wanted this out there and
i believe that's probably true because
he knew some of the evidence that would
be played because johnny depp really has
everyone's like oh he's a wife beater
which he was he has admitted that he has
hit his ex-wife amber heard but also we
see in this trial the tapes where she
literally on tape that she's recording
herself says she beat him in the face
multiple times in one act and he's
calling him a [ __ ] and you know just
it really is these two are toxic just
[ __ ] toxic but uh fox news i want to
read their take this is this is
hilarious this is their take on howard
stern howard stern slams narcissist
johnny depp for overreacting during
amber heard
libel try what the [ __ ] does that mean
what is it so i'm well here's someone in
the comments here i don't know the story
but i some of the comments here says no
he didn't so he didn't hit her
well uh i i well i don't know if he has
or not but i think there is
there is reason to believe that he has
he has hit her um i i don't i don't
think that there is much dispute whether
he has or he hasn't i think this
definitely again i haven't been watching
do you know why i haven't been watching
the donnie johnny depp amber heard trial
do you know why we haven't been talking
about it much
because it's
who gives a rat's ass
i mean really at the end of the day
johnny depp and amber heard are divorced
and they're working out their defamation
in trial
and the judge or whoever is going to
make that decision in the trial uh fox
news again with their with their
headline but the fact that
now howard stern has entered the chat in
this thing and here's um i we tweeted
this this morning uh horse dewormer is
bogus elon musk doesn't own twitter yet
howard stern seems woke
and dr burke was asleep but really
howard stern
this idea that he's woke because he
comments on right i mean he's i mean you
know obviously howard stern is his own
league uh i'm not saying that we're
howard stern but like you know this show
does a very similar thing we are
definitely howard don't yeah okay all
right yeah yeah we are yeah we are the
we are the true woke howard stern that's
right if you want our vote
if you want howard stern type wokeness
you come here to the tony michaels
podcast goddammit but i i i look at this
and i say uh one i don't really give a
[ __ ] about this trial uh but two i also
look at and i say
that's his job right he's got a radio
talk show he talks about stuff that is
in uh current events you know because
he's probably had both of those people
on his show before his guest exactly and
so i would say the same thing here it's
like what we do is more on the political
side of commentary but like there are
other things that come in that are
topical current events
that we talk about and again it's our
opinion
we try to show you know the articles and
the facts of of those uh
do we i feel like i feel like we do a
little bit more research than some you
know coveted idiot but let me try yeah
yeah but again you know at the end at
the end of the day like this is our our
opinion talking about something based on
what we've seen
um
so
you know it's like we're you know it's
like someone coming at us being like oh
oh these guys are giving their opinion
oh [ __ ] them it's like they're super
woke it's like
like i don't know how that equals one or
the other
but in this scenario where fox news like
or others are calling
uh
uh
howard stern super woke like or woke in
general not super but just woke it's
like how does he's just commenting like
he just he's saying what he thinks and
he's paid to say it that's what it is
right and he's been doing it for a long
time it's no different than anyone on
twitter except this guy's paid to say it
on the radio and on right you know
if you haven't if you haven't been
paying attention to who's howard stern
is then yeah stop stop writing tweets
about him um i want to go to some actual
news here and we're going to switch
gears to some action news before we
close out the show here we are 52
minutes into the second hour uh olga
from kremlin files um you know midas
touch has a has a a podcast called
kremlin files
where they talk almost exclusively about
russian putin
which at this time is pretty important
so you might want to go check out those
episodes russia sets their eye on
moldova and that's really the news from
today
apparently they're putting up some
broadcasting antennas and stuff um
she says i'm putting out the warning we
need to pay attention to moldova
and
i you know again i'm not steeped in a
lot of
russian and ukrainian politics but if
you're looking at a map here um this is
uh from her sub stack and you should
probably go read this article here we'll
retweet this uh real quick um everyone
has been talking about moldova this
morning because if you see this red area
here that is crimea and we know that
that russia
aggressively took crimea and then
up here you see kiev and then moldova
over here on the other side um that is
that is probably a strategic area where
russia would like to be
um as far as uh kiev and ukraine is
there to to topple them to topple their
borders so i'm not sure exactly what's
going on uh maybe maybe we should try to
see if we can get aaron parnez on here
to to discuss why
moldova
is such an important
um
why russia thinks it's so important in
their strategy
to take
um ukraine thank you olga for the for
the tweet there um i want to go back to
the moldova here's malcolm nance as
everyone knows malcolm
is over in
ukraine uh he says warning russia
opposed to antagonize and launch attacks
from
how do you say this here
tran
transit history
friends and history uh yeah to
officially seize it
uh three battalion task groups located
and transistia is actually that uh where
moldova is uh is at
um i believe is that correct i believe
that's correct um it's officially seats
uh three battalion task groups located
there with gru spies could be easily
defeated by ukraine and moldova if
their hand is forced
um it's a part it's recognized as a part
of moldova okay so it is it is part of
moldova
um
so
look but it looks like uh here the kia
of independence says russian state
control media uh
transistor it may soon decide to protect
the interest of the republic
um several explosions occurred
on april 25th which ukraine
labeled as false flag operations to stir
tensions so it sounds like they're doing
more false flags and to create more
tension and
have more separation possibly justify
the attack from the south again if you
go back and look
uh let's give credit to this article
here and let's give credit to malcolm
because we read his tweet but i want to
go back and look at that map if you look
at that map that olga had posted there
on her sub stack that is the
the thumbnail for her sub stack um you
see here
that the um
that moldova is in the south now i'm not
sure which region that is a part of
but it is well uh looking at caitlyn
says moldova has a separatist satellite
community just like those in eastern
ukraine in the dunbas and they mostly
speak russian in moldova
so so they so moldova is probably a
sacked full of uh putin uh sympathizers
if that may be the case
and it looks like that's where to pay
attention
um so
pay attention to this this this is real
um actual news not
not [ __ ] that howard stern said [ __ ]
talked about johnny depp
right this is news there are more there
are there's actual and this goes you
know again to the thing that we talked
about last week which was you know we
saw
um mike tyson was trending for punching
some idiot on the plane who was
bothering him and we did that we did the
mike tyson you know that commentary yeah
we talked about it it was trending right
and then what we ended up discussing was
the fact that the supreme court
uh you know basically
doesn't care about puerto rico in terms
of getting the actual benefits and
rights that every other state in the u.s
does because it is a you know it's a
part of the united states it's the
property of the united states
technically
if you'd like to see that clip go
subscribe to the youtube channel i think
we just posted that yesterday right that
that clip of us talking about puerto
rico and i believe so even even the part
about where we're talking about the
trends and how that works right exactly
and that was the main that was the main
thing i wanted to mention is because in
that on that day
mike tyson is number one across the
board and all these things and you go
down it's like something else that was
you know that was paid advertising to be
trending you go down it was the buzz
lightyear uh origin story movie from
pixar and then you get down to the
supreme court's ruling on puerto rico
when you're like
this is the this is the type of news
cycle of world we live in like tony and
i will talk for during the two-hour
period about various things that are
trending some are important and some are
kind of like
very ephemeral in its moment and let's
be honest we're trying to fill two hours
i mean right
sometimes sometimes we already destroyed
no no totally i mean obviously you know
people also need to just like take a
break and be like all right maybe we
don't don't talk about the serious [ __ ]
we try we try to make it to where it's
easy to listen to so you'll stay the
whole time right and listen to the [ __ ]
that possibly will matter sometimes we
talk about tacos sometimes we talk about
right soda water sometimes we talk about
other random things we talked about
benefits uh
wet ass [ __ ] i mean right or dry ass
right yeah yeah yeah exactly i mean but
yeah
you know so the example here is we're
looking to this list and we're like oh
man when when look here
yeah so so the top number one trending
before we leave here is rand paul is
trending number one um which actually
has to do with ukraine and he's
propagating uh putin uh talking points
which does have to do that but it's not
quite the trending topic that i would
like to see but you know that's what it
is um and then you go all the way down
uh here's dr curry that apparently has
something to do with the herd and depth
draw i don't i don't know what i'm not
even getting into that but you got uh
vice president uh kamala harris um
uh test positive for covid so that seems
uh
she's not doesn't have any symptoms that
doesn't seem that important not not
number eight yeah i mean yeah yeah the
vice president kamala harris having
coveted that might be important but if
she's not exhibiting symptoms probably
not number eight folks right um and it's
because we're talking about it and i
don't mean we like me and gabe i mean
everyone out there in the twitter sphere
is is is tweeting about this stuff
because it's important to you and that's
what we're saying it's because it's
important to you like howard stern boom
there it is um mj thank you for the
super sticker there um ivermectin number
13.
and because people are talking about it
today because elon musk bought twitter
and they think they can type the word
ivermectin again which is really dumb um
let's see sean king sean king left
twitter which is really stupid too i
thought he was already gone well i don't
know that's what they're saying this
morning that's the i i honestly i didn't
know sean king was until i seen the
story to be quite honest um but you go
down uh dr burks is trending number 26.
the christmas story is trending number
two i mean you know this is
these are things
and even in the for me like um
are for you for me for me as for me for
me for me as george honestly but i mean
again
this is this is our doing and what i
mean our i mean our collective not mine
engaged i mean we're we can only do so
much yeah i can only push the needle so
far on this step right i mean i can't i
can't i can't um you know change the
trending topics i mean we can tweet
about it and we try we try to tree about
tweet about it we try to talk about it
here on the tony michael's podcast every
single weekday monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central nine pacific for
two full hours youtube twitter twitch
and the mind facebook page like we try
to amplify that talk and we try to do it
in a way that makes it to where you guys
will listen to the important stuff that
may be trending
but we can't always we don't get to
choose what trends we don't get to
choose what happens
again like the elon mustang everyone
today thinks that elon musk has already
bought tw brought twitter
so you can type in the word ivermectin
and you can completely ignore the
important news out of moldova so
don't ignore the important stuff keep
tweeting though don't don't stop stay on
twitter and if you don't want to stay on
twitter don't do that either i don't
care i don't give a [ __ ] and if you want
to up un unsubscribe or unfollow me on
twitter because you're mad about my
opinion i'm not going to stop giving
whatever
good luck yeah good luck oh and by the
way by the way
today's taco tuesday so don't forget
don't forget your daily taco yeah yeah
and i say daily because i'm using tacos
where are you going today i'm probably
going to go to a spot that's down the
street around the corner you know
everybody knows here that gabe is
definitely streaming soda and eating
tacos today
if i could live a life only if i was
like listen if i could do the show eat
tacos and stream soda
we should we should stream you or we
should stream you that's weird we should
stream you eating tacos and streaming
water all at the same time like just
like on twitch one day so so all of our
yeah people want to watch me eat tacos
all day and drink some stream water and
just kind of surf the internet and see
what's going on happy to if that's
something that people want you know
or maybe if you want to do a little only
fans kind of thing that's cool what the
f okay all right that's enough that's
enough okay we'll see you guys tomorrow
again noon eastern 11th century on
youtube twitter twitch and the minus
touch facebook page until then until
noon eastern tomorrow surf's up
[ __ ]
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speaking